Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue over another.
This episode is brought to you by a cent protein,
the cleanest least process protein I've ever consumed and I have tried just
about everything since well before the four hour body.
I've started my day with 20 to 30 grams of protein.
First thing that has been part of my routine,
but I don't always have the time or necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal.
So what to do.
Protein powders can be a fast way to get this protein needs met,
but most products are full of crap.
They're bleached,
they have excess sugar,
terrible artificial sweeteners or just straight forward low grade,
low quality protein ascent contains zero artificial ingredients and the parent
company is actually a cheese manufacturer,
so they produce their own native proteins.
It's,
it's really fascinating and I've looked at they're processing it takes or it
took them about five years to develop.
You can mix the protein in as little as four ounces without any clumps or issues
of mixed ability whatsoever.
And they nailed the taste.
They tested,
for instance,
for the chocolate version 282 different versions.
It put a lot of money and a lot of time into r and D for this particular
product.
If you love coffee,
they also have a brand new cappuccino flavor,
which is a variation I've enjoyed.
If you prefer to test something outside of the traditional vanilla or chocolate
and they have both way in my cellar casing,
so if you want to say improve body composition and recovery overnight slow
release so you can take the my seller casein or in my case whey protein,
I would take postworkout for instance or in the morning,
so check it out.
These guys were really fascinating.
Visit a scent protein.com forward slash Tim,
that's a s,
c e n t p r o t e I n.com a sense like first ascent going up,
a scent protein.com forward slash Tim and you will receive 20% off your entire
purchase.
If you want a very quick 20th 30 gram dose to start your day or after workout,
this is a fantastic option.
It is arguably the best that I've found.
So again,
chicken up a scent,
protein.com forward slash Tim.
Yeah,
this episode is brought to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember foursigmatic for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those clever finished founders.
And when I first mentioned that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week at lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite side of the of new product and that is
their Reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for decades.
I have a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey brain has never been easy,
still isn't easy very often.
And I've found Reishi,
which I've been fascinated by for a few years now,
has been very,
very effective and calming their old formula.
However,
four sigmatic old formula included Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons.
And I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without sweeteners if you'd be open to it,
if too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game for experimentation.
So they created a special custom version without the Stevia,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio elixir comes in single serving packets,
which are perfect for travel and in fact I'm about to leave the country right
now and I have a packet in front of me.
This just going to sit in the end of my carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copy that they put in the read,
so I'm going to read it and then I'll give you my take quote,
a warning for those in the experimental mindset,
Reishi is strong and bitter in parentheses,
like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or nut milk such as almond milk and quote.
So I'm going to say no,
you should suck it up and you should drink the tea because it's not that bitter
and maybe should take the advice of all Chinese people when they're criticizing
young ins.
When they say [inaudible] should a cool,
which means you're not able to eat bitterness.
Bitter is in many cases an indication of things that help liver detoxification
and so on.
Not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio lecture on family members,
on friends,
everybody has liked it.
It's a little bit earthy.
It's not that hard.
So I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put in honey or milk or any of that shit.
Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious I think.
Right?
If you like poo air,
that kind of stuff,
that type of tea,
you're going to dig it.
So just try it.
Okay.
Back to then my read.
If you'd like to naturally improve your sleep,
both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just enjoy this ratio elixir without any sweeteners.
It has organic,
Reishi extract,
organic fueled,
mint extract,
organic rose hips extract,
organic Tulsi extract.
And that's it.
No fancy stuff,
no artificial watching McCall at anything.
So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com forward slash and Ferris and get 20% off this special
batch.
I don't know if they're gonna be making much more of this,
uh,
it since it was made specifically for you guys to do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be open to experimenting with me to create products for
you guys.
Specifically,
check it out for Sigmadek.
That's Fou,
R,
s,
I g m,
a t,
I c.com forward slash Ferris,
F,
e R,
r,
I s,
s and get 20% off the special batch and a,
you must use the code of Ferris to receive a discount.
F,
e R,
r,
I.
S.
So again,
go to foursigmatic.com forward slash Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20% off
of this rare exclusive,
limited run of Reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime routines with out any
sweeteners.
Enjoy.
Well,
hello there.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where it is my job to share
the habits,
tools,
and patterns of world class performers of all different types.
This special episode is shorter than usual and features,
thoughts and recommendations from Debbie Millman,
who in her first appearance on this podcast gave a wide ranging and very
emotionally impactful interview that is still one of the most downloaded
episodes of all time on this podcast.
You can check that out@tim.blog forward slash.
Debbie if you want a longer form conversation,
but this will be a shorter taste of Debbie,
Debbie,
Debbie Millman on Twitter has been called quote,
one of the most influential designers working today and quote by graphic design
USA.
She's the founder and host of design matters,
the world's first and longest running podcast about design where she's
interviewed nearly 300 design luminaries and cultural commentators including
Masimo of Yeley and Milton Glaser.
Debbie has,
I suppose to put it one way done it all.
Her work has been exhibited around the world.
She is the President Ameritus of a IGA,
one of only five women to hold the position and the organization's 100 year
history,
the editorial and creative director of print magazine and the author of six
books in 2009 Debbie cofounded alongside Steven Heller,
the world's first masters program in branding at the school of visual arts in
New York City,
which has received international acclaim.
So she has been on many different adventures in many different fields and has
learned a lot of very,
very impactful lessons that you can apply hopefully to your own life.
In this episode,
Debbie outlines more than a few things,
but among them she talks about how to bounce back from rejection and criticism
and share some of her personal stories,
the importance of mental health,
whether courage or confidence is more important.
If you had to pick one,
five questions to help you clarify your own purpose and much,
much more so.
Without further ado,
please enjoy this shorter episode with Debbie Millman.
Okay.
Debbie,
what is the book or books that you've given most as a gift and why or what?
Or one say two,
three books that have greatly influenced your life?
Well,
a book that has influenced my life and when that I keep going back to over and
over is the anthology,
the voice that is great within us.
American poetry of the 20th century,
gorgeously thoughtfully and carefully edited by Hayden Carruth.
It was required reading in a summary College class I attended back in the early
1980s this funny looking book introduced me to my most treasured,
deeply felt comb maximus to himself by Charles Olson,
which has since become the blueprint of my life as well as the poetry of Denise
Levertov,
Adrienne Rich,
Ezra pound,
Wallace Stevens,
and so many more.
I still have my original copy from the 1980s and the,
the cover has come off and the spine is cracked in numerous places.
I will never replace it.
And Tim,
I thought I'd read a version of Charles Olson's maximus to himself since it is
my favorite poem and I get such great joy reading this
maximus to himself by Charles Olson.
I have had to learn this simplest things last,
which made for difficulties even at sea.
I was slow to get the handout or to cross a wet deck to see was not finally my
trade,
but even my trade at it.
I stayed a strange from that which was most familiar,
was delayed and not content with the man's argument that such postponement is
now the nature of obedience,
that we are all late in a slow time,
that we grew up many and the single is not easily known.
It could be though the sharpness,
the ACI oat I note in others makes more sense than my own distances.
The agility's they show daily who do the world's businesses and who do natures
as I have no sense.
I have done either.
I've made dialogs,
have discussed ancient texts have thrown what light I could offered,
what pleasures do seat allows,
but the known this I have had to be given a life love and from one man the world
tokens,
but sitting here I look out as a wind and water man testing and missing some
proof.
I know the quarters of the weather where it comes from,
where it goes,
but the stem of me,
this I took from their welcome or their rejection of me and my arrogance was
neither diminished nor increased by the communication.
It is undone business.
I speak of this morning with the sea stretching out from my feet.
What purchase of $100 or less has most positively impacted your life in the last
six months or in recent memory?
One of the purchase that has influenced me over the last six months is the apple
pencil.
I do so much of my artwork by hand and now there is a device that draws and
feels like a real pencil that I can use electronically.
It's changed the way I work.
How has a failure or apparent failure set you up for later success?
Do you have a favorite failure and quote of yours?
Oh,
Tim,
I have so many failures.
I think the first decade of my career were experiments and failure,
rejection and humiliation,
but I do have a favorite so I will share that.
In early 2003 a good friend sent me an email with a subject line that red begin
drinking heavily before opening the email contained a link to a blog titled
Speak Up.
The first ever online forum about graphic design and branding in the world
suddenly sprawled before my eyes.
I found myself reading an article that disparaged my entire career.
This particular incident in tandem with a number of historical rejections and
setbacks and humiliations sent me into a really deep depression and I seriously
considered leaving the design profession altogether.
However,
however,
in the 14 years since this occurred,
this utter takedown of everything I'd done to date and everything I thought was
a complete and total failure for a long,
long time ultimately transformed into the foundation of everything I've done
since everything I am doing now contains the seeds of origin from that time.
So it turns out for me the worst professional experience I've faced ultimately
became the most important defining experience of my life.
Debbie,
if you could have a giant billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say and why?
This is easy.
My billboard would save this busy is a decision.
I say this all the time ad nauseum and here's why.
Of the many,
many excuses people use to rationalize why they can't do something.
The excuse I am too busy is not only the most inauthentic.
It is also the laziest.
I don't believe in too busy.
Busy is a decision we do the things we want to do period.
If we say we're too busy,
I believe it is shorthand for not important enough.
It means you would rather be doing something else that you consider more
important.
That thing could be sleep.
It could be sex,
it could be watching game of Thrones.
If we use busy as an excuse for not doing something,
what we are really,
really saying is that it's not a priority.
It's not as important to us,
so simply put,
you don't find the time to do something.
You make the time to do things.
I think we're now living in a society that sees busy as a badge.
It has become cachet to use the excuse.
I am too busy as a reason for not doing anything.
We don't feel like doing.
The problem is this.
If you let yourself off the hook for not doing something for any reason,
you won't ever do it.
If you want to do something,
you can't let being busy stand in the way.
Even if you are busy,
make the time to do the things you want to do and then follow through and do
them.
What is one of the best or most worthwhile investments you've ever made?
This answer might surprise you or maybe not,
but the best investment I've ever made was in psychotherapy.
When I first started,
I was in my early thirties and the bills practically killed me,
but I knew I needed to deeply understand all the destructive things that had
happened to me in order to try to live a remarkable life despite these things,
and I wanted this more than anything over the years.
I still sometimes smart at the mum at the monthly invoices,
but I've never doubted that this investment has profoundly,
profoundly shaped who I've become.
And although I still think I have a lot of work to do,
it's changed and then saved my life in every imaginable way.
And I'm in what is called psychoanalytic psychotherapy.
Put another way,
psycho analysis with an emphasis on self psychology.
And so for me,
talk therapy is the only thing that I've ever really felt drawn to.
Things like EMDR and behavior modification might be really,
really helpful for other people,
but they seem a little bit to Voodoo for me.
So some things that I think are important to consider strictly from my
perspective,
I'm not an expert at assessing or analyzing the value or worth of psycho
analysis only.
I am able to convey what this has done for me.
Um,
but for,
for me,
once a week therapy did not work well twice or more gives you a continuity and
an opportunity to germinate in a way that once a week doesn't.
Also,
once a week almost feels like a catch up.
You sort of bring the therapist up to speed on what happened in the last week
and then you have 20 minutes to sort of talk about what's happening right now.
Therapy takes time.
I often say that anything worthwhile takes a long time and therapy is one of
those things.
I've been in therapy for a really long time for decades,
but I can now after those decades actually point to empirical evidence of how my
behavior in the world by my sense of who I am has fundamentally fundamentally
changed.
And so being in therapy and being in therapy for any length of time,
it takes dedication.
It takes stamina,
it takes resilience,
persistence,
and a lot of courage to face things that you might be really afraid to look at.
So it's not a quick fix,
but,
but like I said,
it's really saved my life.
Try and tell your therapist everything.
If you edit who you are or if you pretend to be something that you're not in
order to impress the therapist.
If you want to project who were how you want to be seen,
it will take that much longer.
So just be yourself.
They've likely in their practice,
heard everything they understand humanity.
So just be yourself.
If you're afraid your therapist will judge you.
Tell them that also because that whole projection is really critical to
understanding the dynamic that you have with people in general.
So all of these things are really important to talk about.
There is no shame in feeling shame.
And I'm saying this from a place of deep empathy.
Almost everyone feels shame.
I think Renee Brown says that anybody that doesn't feel shame is likely,
um,
a pathological person.
So almost everyone does in therapy will help you understand it.
There was nothing like understanding your motivations and insecurities to help
you integrate all of those feelings in your psyche in the most healthy and
authentic way.
So for me,
I would not recommend going to a therapist that one of your friends goes to
asking your friends for,
for all.
And then going to somebody that they see might seem like a good idea because
that person trusts them.
And therefore by extension you might feel like you can too.
But it ends up blurring things.
Um,
quite a bit.
And I think most therapists abide by this rule now of not seeing friends of or
clients of,
of friends.
Um,
things really do get very blurry and boundaries can get weird and I just don't
recommend that.
Okay,
big elephant in the room here.
It is going to be expensive.
But what is more valuable than better understanding who you are,
breaking intrinsic bad habits,
getting over much of your shit or at least understanding why you do the shit in
the first place and generally living a happier,
more contented,
more peaceful life.
One thing that I've come to understand recently,
and this was actually not only through the help of my therapist and guidance
from my therapist,
but also through my dear,
dear friend Seth Goden is understanding the difference between happiness and
pleasure.
And I think people are often trying to reach for and strive for pleasure and,
and the response to trying to seek pleasure is actually wanting more pleasure
after that.
You know,
we live on this hedonistic treadmill,
we metabolize our purchases and our experiences very quickly.
And so when we have that pleasure or experience that pleasure,
then we want more.
Happiness is very different.
Happiness essentially means you're okay as is,
you don't need more,
you don't want more,
you feel good with what you have.
And I think that therapy really helps you understand the difference between what
you see,
what your motivations are,
and ultimately what you want and how you can manifest that in your life.
So breaking these intrinsic bad habits,
getting over much of your shit and generally living this happier,
more contented,
more peaceful life is something that I think is the ultimate gift of therapy or
the payoff.
And,
and lastly,
my advice to anyone looking for a therapist is to make sure they're really
trained eye.
I highly recommend training here,
a phd and MD plus postdoctoral training.
You really do get what you pay for here.
And I highly recommend somebody that is truly fully educated in what they do.
What is an unusual habit or an absurd thing that you love?
I've been told that because I like to make up silly songs and then sing them in
all sorts of absurd situations and occurrences that I am trying to turn my life
into a Hollywood musical.
And,
and since I was first told that I've come to completely agree with that and I
think that is awesome.
But I have songs for everything.
I have songs,
I used to have songs for feeding my cats,
but they've,
since both passed away,
I have songs for my dogs.
I have songs while I'm cooking.
I usually take some well known tune and then rewrite the lyrics for whatever it
is I'm experiencing.
So for example,
when I was feeding my cats,
when I would open up the cans of cat food,
I would sing,
who wants said fancy?
Who wants,
if Iste,
who wants it fancy?
Who wants it?
Sti.
Feastly fancy,
fancy.
Festy let's open up the cans now.
They loved it.
Everybody else around me hated it,
but they loved it.
In the last five years,
what new belief,
behavior,
or habit has most improved your life after a design matters interview with the
great writer Danny Shapiro,
we started to talk about the role of confidence in success.
Apparently,
I think at that time about four new books on confidence had come out and she
went on to state that she felt that confidence was highly overrated and I was
instantly intrigued and asked her why,
and she explained that she felt that most people that she felt that most overly
confident people were really annoying and that most confident people,
we're usually a little bit on the arrogant side.
She felt that over exuding that amount of confidence was a sure sign that a
person was compensating for some type of internal psychological deficit.
Instead,
Danny declared that courage was more important than confidence.
Taking that first step in doing anything was the real key to begin to manifest
the possibility of that thing happening.
So when you're operating out of courage,
you're saying that no matter how you feel about yourself or your opportunities
or the outcome,
you're going to take a risk and take a step toward what you want.
You're not waiting for the confidence to mysteriously arrive.
And since then I've been thinking a lot about,
well how do you develop confidence?
How do you,
how do you bring that confidence to whatever it is you do?
And I've come to the conclusion that,
and this is my definition of,
of confidence now,
is that confidence is the successful repetition of any endeavor.
So if you think back to something that you had to learn for the first time
walking,
for example,
you didn't start walking and just start walking perfectly.
You were crawling,
you are holding onto things.
And then ultimately you get that ability to step up and take that first step and
then you learn how to walk.
But even a better example I think is,
I think he's driving when most of us start driving,
we have to take driving lessons were really nervous about being in the car.
Behind the wheel.
We have this big instrument that we have to control.
Most of us were really,
really nervous at a driver tea at her driving test and are hoping and praying
that we'll be able to pass.
But over time when she do pass,
once you have your license,
you start driving more regularly.
You turn on the ignition and you drive around,
you do your errands,
you take road trips,
cross country trips,
whatever.
And after a certain amount of time when you get into the car and turn on the
ignition,
you don't worry about the possibility that this might be the day that you kill
someone behind the wheel.
You have what I call car confidence.
You get in the car,
you know how to drive and you figure that you're going to be able to get from
point a to point B.
Um,
rather unremarkably.
And I think that that is the case for anything that we do.
Anything new that we start,
it's highly unlikely that we will feel enormously confident doing something
we've never done before.
It takes time to be able to manifest confidence through the successful
repetition of any endeavor.
We ended up having a certain internal pattern recognition by the fact that we've
done this thing before fairly well,
maybe excellently and we anticipate that the results will be the same the next
time we do it.
So the more you practice doing something,
the better you will inevitably get at it and your confidence will then grow over
time.
What advice would you give to a smart driven college student about to enter the
real world?
Or what advice do you think they should ignore?
Well,
since I teach,
I have a lot of opinions on what advice to give college students.
I think one of the most important is about job hunting.
Like everything else meaningful in life.
It takes training to get good at job hunting.
You don't just find and get a great job,
you know,
just go to the supermarket and pick a great job off of a shelf.
You have to find and win a great job against a pool,
a very competitive candidates who may want that job as much if not more than you
do.
So finding and winning a great job.
It's a competitive sport that requires as much career athleticism and
perseverance as making it to the Olympics.
You must be in the finest career shape possible in order to win.
There is very little luck involved and I've done hundreds of design matters
interviews where I'm sitting across people,
really successful people that say,
oh,
it was just luck.
I just got lucky.
And I look at them and I always say really?
Because it's very little to do with luck.
There might be some timing involved,
but it's the timing that is resulting in showing up every day,
doing the work,
getting better and better and better at the work and then being the person most
qualified when that opportunity shows up.
Winning your great job is about hard work.
It's about stamina,
it's about grit,
ingenuity and timing.
And what might look like look to you is simply hard work paying off.
So here's some questions I tell my students to ask themselves as they sat out on
their path in the real world to win a job.
Am I spending enough time on looking for finding and working toward winning a
great job?
And my constantly refining and improving my skills.
What can I continue to get better and more competitive at two I believe that I
am working harder than everyone else.
If not,
what can and should I be doing in order to be able to accomplish that?
What are the people who are competing with me doing that I am not doing?
Am I doing everything I can every single day to stay in career shape?
If not,
what else should I be doing?
One piece of advice I think that people should ignore is the value of being a
people person because as lovely as it might be to be a people person,
no one cares if you're a people person,
have a point of view and share it meaningfully,
thoughtfully,
respectfully,
and with conviction.
What are bad recommendations you hear in your profession or area of expertise?
I don't believe in work life balance.
I believe if you view your work as a calling,
it is a labor of love rather than laborious.
When your work is a calling,
you're not approaching the amount of hours you were working with with a sense of
dread or counting.
The minutes until the weekend you're calling can become a life affirming
engagement that can provide its own balance and spiritual nourishment and
ironically,
it takes hard work to achieve this.
So when you're in your twenties and your thirties and you want to have a
remarkable fulfilling career,
you must work hard.
If you don't work harder than everyone else,
you will not get ahead.
Also,
if you're looking for work life balance in your 20s or 30s you're likely in the
wrong career.
If you're doing something that you love,
you don't want work life balance.
You want to be able to do this thing that you love as often as possible.
When you feel overwhelmed or unfocused,
what do you do?
Well,
as a loud mouth native New Yorker,
I have often regretted acting impulsively when I'm feeling angry or frustrated
and now when I feel that familiar,
urge to respond defensively or see things that I don't really mean or bang out a
wounded response via email or text to some,
suppose it hurt.
I wait,
I forced myself to breathe.
Take a step back and wait to respond just an hour or two or an overnight retreat
makes a world of difference and if all else fails,
I tried to obey this message I got in a fortune cookie,
which I've since taped to my laptop.
Avoid compulsively making things worse.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those clever finished founders.
And when I first mentioned that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week.
It lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite side of the spectrum of new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for decades.
I have a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey brain has never been easy.
It still isn't easy very often.
And I found Reishi,
which I've been fascinated by for a few years now,
has been very,
very effective and calming their old formula.
However,
four sigmatic old formula included Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without sweeteners if you'd be open to it.
Too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game for experimentation.
And so they created a special custom version without the Stevia,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio looks or comes in single serving packets,
which are perfect for travel.
And in fact,
I'm about to leave the country right now and I have a packet in front of me
that's just going to sit in the end of my carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copies that they put in the read.
So I'm going to read it and I'll give you my take quote,
a warning for those.
And the experimental mindset.
Reishi is strong and bitter in parentheses,
like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or nut milk such as almond milk and quote.
So I'm going to say no,
you should suck it up and you should drink the tea because it's not that bitter.
And maybe should take the advice of all Chinese people when they're criticizing
young ins.
When they say food,
I'm sure.
Cool.
Which means you're not able to eat bitterness.
Bitterness is in many cases and indication of things that help liver
detoxification and so on.
Not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio lecture on family members,
on friends.
Everybody has liked it.
It's a little bit,
or if the,
it's not that hard.
So I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put it in honey or milk or any of that ship.
Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious.
I think.
I feel like who air and that kind of stuff,
that type of teeth,
you're going to dig it.
So just try it.
Okay.
Back to then my read.
If you'd like to naturally improve your sleep,
both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just enjoy this ratio lecture without any
sweeteners.
It has organic,
Reishi extract,
organic field,
mint extract,
organic rose hips extract,
organic Tulsi extract.
And that's it.
No fancy stuff,
no artificial watching McCall at anything.
So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com ports Ferris and get 20% off this special batch.
I don't know if they're gonna be making much more of this,
uh,
since it was made specifically for you guys to do me a favor and try it out so
that they continue to be open to experimenting with me to create products for
you guys.
Specifically.
Check it out.
Four sigmatic,
that's Flur,
s I g m a t I C.
Dot com.
Forward Slash Ferris,
F,
e R,
R.
I s.
S.
Get 20% off a special batch and you must use the code,
the Ferris to receive a discount.
F.
E.
R.
I s s so again going to foursigmatic.com forward slash Ferris and then use code
Ferris for 20% off of this rare exclusive limited run of Reishi mushroom elixir
for nighttime routines with out any sweeteners.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you by a cent routine,
the cleanest least process protein I've ever consumed and I have tried just
about everything since well before the four hour body.
I've started my day with 20 to 30 grams of protein.
First thing that has been part of my routine,
but I don't always have the time or necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal,
so what to do.
Protein powders can be a fast way to get this protein needs met,
but most products are full of crap.
They're bleached,
they've excess sugar,
terrible artificial sweeteners for just straightforward low grade,
low quality protein.
Ascent contains zero artificial ingredients and the parent company is actually a
cheese manufacturer so that they produced their own native proteins.
It's,
it's really fascinating and I've looked at they're processing it takes or it
took them about five years to develop.
You can mix the protein in as little as four ounces without any clumps or issues
of mixed ability whatsoever,
and they nailed the taste of the tested.
For instance,
the chocolate version 282 different versions of it,
a lot of money and a lot of time into r and d for this particular product.
If you love coffee,
they also have a brand new cappuccino flavor,
which is a variation I've enjoyed.
If you prefer to test something outside of the traditional vanilla or chocolate
and they have both way and my seller casing,
so if you want to say improve body composition and recovery overnight slow
release,
you can take to my seller Casein for,
in my case with whey protein,
I would take postworkout for instance,
four in the morning,
so check it out.
These guys were really fascinating.
Visit ascent routine.com forward slash Tim,
that's a s,
c e n t p r o t e,
I n.com a sense like first ascent going up,
a scent protein.com forward slash Tim and you will receive 20% off your entire
purchase.
If you want a three quick please,
30 gram dose to start your day or after workout.
This is a fantastic option.
It is arguably the best that I've found.
So again,
chicken up a scent,
protein.com forward slash 10.